michael van der veen que inicia entonces
esta defensa de donde dice que
efectivamente van a ser tres horas tres
horas en las que van a hablar los cuatro
abogados de donald trump que son bruce
caster davidson michael van der veen que
está hablando en este momento y william
brennan dice una frase que llama mucho
la atención y es que el los hechos de
violencia del 6 de enero ya estaban
planeados por extremistas que se lo
habían planificado todo mucho antes así
que dice que no se puede incitar a un
acto de violencia que ya estaba planeado
y que por eso entonces el presidente el
ex presidente de donald trump pues no
tendría responsabilidad en los hechos
hechos que según él ya estaban premiados
por estos extremistas dijo además que
entre estos extremistas había un líder
de antifa que es el movimiento
socialista de extrema izquierda según
dice este abogado dijeron también que
usted mencionaba bien
que si los demócratas también han
actuado y han dicho palabras que han
incitado a la violencia haciendo
a la violencia en muchas ciudades del
país se importan oregón y en otras
ciudades donde los movimientos de
centroizquierda y activistas y
activistas en pro de los afroamericanos
pues se generaron desmanes y que fueron
los mismos oficiales demócratas incluso
citó a la vicepresidenta cámara jarvis
como las palabras de ellos pues
incitaron aún más a la violencia resaltó
varias veces y a través de varios vídeos
como donald trump salió públicamente a
decir que el partido republicano en el
partido de la ley y el orden y que él
nunca había incitado a la violencia que
las palabras fueron sacadas de contexto
cuando él dijo que había que pelear como
en el infierno en realidad dijo el
abogado que trump obviamente no se
refería a que fueran sus simpatizantes
al capitolio a pelear físicamente y a
tomarse el capitolio que simplemente
estaba pidiendo fuerza para defender la
democracia y defender lo que él ha
argumentado el ex presidente de donald
trump vale en varias ocasiones que es el
robo en las elecciones presidenciales
palabras
que no según los abogados tienen vínculo
entonces con la violencia ocurrida el 6
de enero